printers are the worst of the worst they
struggle to connect to the Wi-Fi they
constantly have paper jams and don't get
me started on the ludicrous price of ink
it seems that printers are one of the
few Tech Industries that have been
completely left behind I mean you can
buy full-on computers and smartphones
for less than the price of a new printer
yet printers can't even do the one task
that they're built for printing it's
easy to blame the printer industry as a
whole and say that printer companies are
simply unimaginative and not Innovative
but the issue with printers is a lot
more deep rooted than uninspired
companies and lackluster products the
real reason printers are so crappy is
due to Decades of hyper focus on
maximizing Revenue through one Avenue
ink it's not uncommon for printering to
exceed eighty dollars per ounce for
perspective even human blood only costs
17 dollars per ounce and silver costs 34
dollars per ounce in fact selling ink is
so profitable that it accounted for 63
percent of all of hpings profits in
2019. it wasn't always like this in fact
50 to 60 years ago printers were the
cream of the crop they were the best
that the tech world had to offer and
they worked beautifully back in the
1960s Xerox literally made a commercial
showcasing how even a chimpanzee could
operate a photocopier printer operators
were so insulted after this airing that
Xerox would decide to cancel the
commercial just one day later but that
doesn't take away from the message of
the commercial printers were once easy
enough for a train to chimpanzees to use
but today even at trained a rocket
scientists at Nasa can't figure out how
to operate these darn things so what
happened how did printers go from being
the Forefront of the tech industry and
the entire business of one of the
biggest companies in the world Xerox to
being the laughing stock of the tech
industry and the endless frustration of
hundreds of millions of office workers
around the world well sit back and grab
a stress ball because this is exactly
how printers became the bane of our
existence
foreign
taking a look back printers are by no
means a new invention it's theorized
that printers May date as far back as
3500 BC to the Persians and the
Mesopotamians who use cylinders to seal
documents similar to what we do today
but the modern printing press didn't
come around until the year 1440 when a
German Goldsmith named Johannes
Gutenberg invented the movable type
printing press this was a true
Revolution as the alternative was hand
printing which was limited to about 40
pages per day gutenberg's printing press
put that number to shame as it could
produce 3600 pages every single day over
the next couple hundred years the
printing press became the gold standard
for printing religious literature
newspapers and books eventually moving
into the 1990s there arose a new purpose
for printing people and corporations
alike needed an easy way to copy
existing documents at a small scale they
wanted to have additional copies of
their bond and land certificates and
their employment contract but while the
printing press was great at replicating
a given piece of text like a Bible at
skill it wasn't all that great when it
came to replicating individual documents
and the pages Chester Carlson a law
student in the late 1930s knew this pin
all too well you see Chester couldn't
afford to buy law books outright so he
would go to the library and
painstakingly transcribe books onto
sheets of paper it was during one of
these arduous copying sessions that he
came across a scientific article by a
Hungarian physicist named Paul celani
selenia Loosely described how you could
use physics and more specifically
electrophotography to duplicate
documents more effectively Carlson would
begin trying to do electrophotography in
his apartment which led to a bunch of
smoke autoromas and even explosions his
neighbors probably suspected that he was
smoking up as something else but Carlson
persisted and with the help of a friend
he would produce the following piece of
text on October 22nd 1938. Carlson was
sure to patent this technology as soon
as possible and eventually he would
partner with an up-and-coming company
called The Howard company together they
would create what we all know as Xerox
today but it was by no means an easy
Road there was one major flaw with
Carlson's invention it was
extraordinarily difficult to use to be
honest I think we'd agree that
electrophotography is probably easier
than what we have today but nonetheless
Carlson wanted to make it even easier
with backing from Xerox Carlson would
spend the next 21 years of his life
trying to simplify each and every step
of the process and eventually in 1959 he
would crack the code with the Xerox 914
this was the photocopier that was so
easy to use that even a chimpanzee could
use it leading us into the Golden Era of
printers
thank you
it may be hard to believe that printers
were actually good at one point in time
so I'm sure you'll be believed to hear
that there was a massive caveat yes the
Xerox 914 and all of their photocopiers
and printers that followed in the 60s
and 70s and even 80s were extraordinary
but and it wasn't just the product that
was extraordinary it was also the price
tag the cost to make a Xerox 914 was
simply so expensive that they didn't
even try to sell it instead it it was
ordered to renting them out to local
photocopying shops and offices for 25
per month or 238 dollars today customers
would have to pay 10 cents per copy or
96 cents today customers were also
responsible for bringing their own paper
and ink which usually ran about 5 cents
per copy so all in customers were paying
over a dollar for every single page that
they were printing they would get their
wish but it would cost them an absolute
Fortune coming in at 27 1 to 500 that's
the same as 262 thousand dollars today
photocopying it was obviously not cheap
but it was more than worth it for
important documents I mean the
consequences of losing a land deed or a
bond certificate were far worse than
spending a dollar to have an extra copy
this proved to be insanely profitable
for Xerox and by 1970 Xerox would have
become a Fortune 100 company which for a
tech company was at the time unheard of
Xerox would invest a crap ton of money
into research and development and they
actually came up with outstanding
inventions Not only would they make
printers way better but they would
literally invent laptops ethernet coding
languages text editors and so much more
now they were so Gunk hoe on printers
that they would end up giving all of
these away but that's a whole other
Story the point is that they were truly
maintaining printers at the Forefront of
Technology but but with that they were
also charging an arm and a leg and
keeping up the renting model for obvious
reasons having people pay per copy was a
far better business decision for Xerox
than trying to sell printers outright
but the reality was that things were
changing once again the need to
photocopy was quickly being replaced by
the need to print digital documents
fortunately it was a Xerox who invented
text editors and the ability to print
text documents but there was one problem
you had to go to a Xerox shop if you
were already using a computer Cafe it
made sense to USD Xerox printer in the
building but while computer and internet
cafes were super popular back in the day
people would eventually ditch these for
personal computers in the comfort of
their homes and traveling to Xerox shops
just to print stuff out quickly became
an inconvenience HP appsena and the
Canon were all watching this from the
sidelines and they decided that this was
the perfect time to strike
foreign
the first mass-market residential Inc
jet printer was the HP Deskjet 500 which
came out in 1988. like it's at Xerox
predecessors this was truly an
engineering Masterpiece in fact it was
so good that the journalist like Scott
Merrill were raving about it 22 years
later the HP Deskjet 500 was a Workhorse
it never failed to be in college or
Beyond I printed a lot and never had a
paper jam everything I threw at the
Deskjet 500 it printed everything but if
printers were so good what happened well
it turns out that asking people to pay a
thousand dollars for a printer in 1988
was a pretty large ask with budget
computer Brands like Dell popping up you
could literally buy an entire computer
for that price so why would you spend
the same amount on just getting a
printing machine if these companies
really wanted to create a personal
printer Market they had to make printers
cheaper way cheaper but this was much
easier said than done just because
computers offered a better value for
your money didn't mean that it was any
cheaper to design or produce printers
but that was irrelevant to end consumers
if you wanted to appeal to them it was
up to you to figure out how to make
printers cheap enough for everyday
people with all these Mega companies
working on this you would think that
some engineer somewhere would make a
Monumental breakthrough that
substantially simplified printers and
made them far cheaper but this never
happened instead printer manufacturers
just decided to sell printers for a loss
they figured that they could just make
the money on the ink and somehow 30
years later they're still using the same
strategy and they've only gotten more
aggressive the reason that printers are
affordable today is not because they're
cheaper to make but because companies
are willing to take bigger and bigger
losses but with that being said when you
are selling a product for a loss you're
naturally not going to invest into r d
testing reliability or ease of use
instead you're gonna put out an MVP or a
minimum liable product and that this is
the reality of the entire consumer
printer industry today the reason
printers are so bad is because every
company is trying to shrink an extremely
complex product into an MVP I mean just
think about it a printer has to put
millions of dots onto a piece of paper
within a matter of seconds there's no
way that such a complex product can work
as an MVP that's sold for a loss printer
companies should be thinking about how
to engineer better printers but given
that that's not where the money is
printer companies have been spending all
of their efforts on how to sell as much
ink as possible and this has led to some
pretty anti-consumer inventions some
companies will straight up prevent you
from using counterfeit ink through
software but even if they don't go that
far they'll make sure that you feel the
pain for example the printheads of mini
printers are actually located on the ink
cartridge this means that the quality of
your print will only be as good as the
incubine so if you bought some
counterfeit cartridges and noticed that
the quality Went Done substantially this
is probably why
foreign
looking forward the future of printers
isn't looking any brighter because
printers as a whole are going extinct
here's the thing one of the main reasons
that printers became so popular in the
first place was because of trust people
didn't trust computers as much as they
trusted themselves they wanted hard
copies of important documents they
wanted real signatures that felt
authentic but today printers are
becoming Irrelevant for the exact same
reason trust this time though it's
themselves that people don't trust
people and companies alike don't want to
have filing cabinets full of documents
they don't want to hold on to 200 Page
contracts that are fatter than books and
they trust the cloud and 7 backups
across the world more than a singular
hard copy at this point hard copies are
more of a formality than anything
everything from buying a house to
completing an acquisition can be done
completely digitally and this is what
people actually prefer so with that
being said it doesn't make sense for any
you want to double down on the printer
industry and try to make it better the
more likely scenario is that printers
will go extinct and the last memory that
we'll have of them is good riddance do
you hate printers comment that down
below also drop a like if you trust
computers more than yourself and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest for your video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
foreign